Let's go next to our caller from the six zero
one area code.
Who's calling today from six zero one hello,
David?
Yes.
Who's this?
Hey, my is Houston.
All right.
Houston.
What's going on
in Mississippi?
Euston in Mississippi.
I love it.
Currently outside on break in between classes.
I had a question kind of regarding the governor's
race and more local politics in general.
Uh, Mississippi has a very unique system of
how we elect our governor and it's, we have
districts and to win the governor's seat,
you have to get more than 50% of the vote
overall.
But also you have to win districts, right?
It's an electoral college system, but worse.
And if no candidate went both 50% or all the
districts, then the representatives to the
house just decide to, the governor is out
at the top two.
Indeed.
[inaudible]
and my question really comes in of how does
any progressive fight in a system like that
for any change where it feels like there's
just a wall of disenfranchise disenfranchisement.
Sorry, I totally called out here.
Yeah.
Well, so listen you did, this is why local
politics matters.
You have to elect candidates who say that
they will lobby to change that.
And of course this is the fundamental difficulty
with a lot of the systems that we have.
The system is set up to reinforce the status
quo that elects the people that are there.
It's sort of like with term limits, term limits,
excuse me.
Or campaign finance are the elected officials
that were elected by the campaign finance
system.
We have going to be motivated to do away with
that system.
Only the most principled minority is going
to do that, sadly.
Um, so it's the same type of thing with the
Mississippi system.
You, we, you need to start electing people
to the legislature who say that they will
lobby to have that changed and have a governor
that's willing to go along with it.
But that's the system that got them there.
So why would they do that?
Yeah, yeah.
It's a bit of a, it's a bit of a dream killer
of a system, but we've got, that's why we
keep fighting.
Absolutely.
All right.
Thank you so much for the call.
It's windy there.
So I'm going to let you go.
I hope it's not so strong that, that, uh,
it's causing you a problem getting around.
But the thank you for the call.